[Musique]
et cette invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
Germaine inconnu bonjour et bienvenue
sur ce plateau chorégraphe danseuse vous
êtes sénégalaise d'adoption on est au
Bénin l'un des très grands noms de la
danse contemporaine on est très heureux
de vous accueillir ce matin pour parler
entre autre de votre dernier projet Le
Sacre du Printemps qui est présenté en
ce moment au Théâtre de la Ville à Paris
à la Villette précisément dansé par une
quarantaine de danseurs que vous avez
formé dans l'école de danse l'école des
sables que vous avez monté au Sénégal et
on va revenir sur l'histoire de l'école
qui est assez incroyable dans un instant
c'est danseur et c'est une première
vienne d'une quinzaine de pays africains
on a gardé quelques images du ballet et
on en parle juste après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà pour y être allé je confirme que
c'est une stalingovation tous les soirs
qu'est-ce que vous ressentez quand vous
voyez ces danseurs au passionnés comme
ça à Paris
tous les soirs je regarde avec mon mari
Helmut for nous sommes les fondateurs de
l'école des sables mais de voir ce
résultat extraordinaire entre sur Thomas
les transmetteurs comme je les appelle
ceux qui ont dansé avec Pina barge qui
transmettent avec beaucoup de rigueur et
aussi beaucoup d'attention de respect
culture entre culture et vraiment quand
je vois le résultat de ce travail entre
les Africains et les transmetteurs je
trouve ça extraordinaire de précision de
rigueur de
d'énergie et musicalité lyrique y a tout
quoi le Sacre du printemps pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas c'est un balai
mythique qui avait choqué au moment de
sa création au
vous avez un rapport personnel avec ce
ballet vous avez dans ses biens sur la
version de Maurice Béjart que vous avez
accompagné pendant des années Dubois
c'était Olivier Dubois j'ai dansé mon
élu noir de la musique de strasset
mais il en a fait une version c'est un
balai qui porte en lui quelque chose
vous le disiez depuis 100 et quelque
chose de terrifiant aussi absolument de
terrifiant mais aussi d'espoir parce que
l'espoir c'est il faut regarder la
réalité en face donc regardez la réalité
en face de voir qu'on va sacrifier un
être pour le bien-être de tous et ben
c'est pas facile c'est pas facile à
accepter mais bon si pour eux le
bien-être de tous on doit sacrifier
quelqu'un il faut accepter mais je
trouve que la dent justement cette
puissance de la danse
fait que l'être qui meurt ne meurt
jamais je dis que les morts ne mordent
ne meurent pas ils sont dans le vent ils
sont dans les feuilles ils sont partout
ils sont avec nous mais mort ils sont
bénéfiques et c'est le propose ça de la
première partie du sexe
quelques mois c'est très beau parce que
vous le dansez avec une des grandes
danseuses de pinache justement
c'est comme ça que vous introduisez ce
cette deuxième partie alors ce projet
avec l'eau on le disait grâce à votre
école des sables qui est un centre
international de danse africaine
traditionnelle et contemporaine qui a
tout babiala au Sénégal c'est le projet
de votre vie j'imagine à quel à quel
impératif répondait-il ce projet pour
vous et ben moi j'étais directrice de
mon droit africain a été créée par
Maurice Béja c'est mon rapport avec
Maurice Beja qui voulait aussi que le
sacre soit dansé malheureusement ça n'a
pas été fait et justement je dis une
idée ne meurt jamais quand j'ai
rencontré Helmut mon époux 1982 nous
avons eu de cesse que de refaire cette
école de formation importante pour
l'Afrique et leur donner affronter leur
sport par la danse donc au départ nous
avons commencé par nos propres moyens
nous avons eu des aides mais
malheureusement ça continue pas et je
trouve avec tous les prix que j'ai eu je
souhaite avoir un prix avec beaucoup
d'argent pour continuer à former ces
danseurs ou je fais appel au monde aux
africains aux Européens parce que le
monde entier vient à l'école des sables
et puis mais c'est un plaisir c'est
quelque chose d'extraordinaire quand on
voit le résultat du travail par ces
jeunes qui affrontent leur vie par la
danse et gagne leur vie aide à vivre
n'est-ce pas je trouve cela
extraordinaire et c'est un bien immense
alors il s'agit les danseurs qu'on voit
en ce moment à Paris donc ils viennent
d'une quinzaine de pays africains je
crois ils sont venus de tout le
continent pour voilà pour venir danser
avec vous qu'est-ce qu'ils ont envie de
dire qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que la
danse africaine contemporaine a envie de
dire aujourd'hui
apporte une vérité comme
nous sommes les hommes de la danse dans
les pieds reprennent vigueur en francs
par le sol dur et justement vous savez
ce projet depuis Naba qui a été initié
par seul au barge qui a vu
l'extraordinaire
danseur de l'école des sables a demandé
que ce
ce le pin
le sacre soit transmis aux africains
mais je trouve que j'ai dit que ça doit
être exactement la même chorégraphie
transmis à vos portables que soient
transmis aux Africains et j'ai dit que
le l'émotion ne se trouve pas dans le
coup de pied ils ont pas fait du
classique il y en a qui viennent de la
danse traditionnelle de la danse urbaine
et ce qui prouve pour moi c'est toujours
dit que les danses africaines c'est la
mère de toutes les danses parce que le
mouvement est né en Afrique et cela
prouve avec cette bigger avec cette
rigueur avec cette puissance cette
puissance des danseurs que l'Afrique est
là l'Afrique est là et surtout après les
événements du covid et je trouve que il
y a eu un moment de mort de silence et
aussi ce qui passe en Ukraine je trouve
que quand les gens sortent de ce
spectacle ils sont heureux ils sont
vivants ils sont heureux et cette joie
cet espoir qu'on apporte au monde c'est
extraordinaire la pandémie effectivement
qui a retardé je crois de deux ans la
présentation du spectacle vous étiez
prêt et puis là tout s'est arrêté est-ce
que pendant ces deux ans on a parlé de
gestes barrières de surtout bien garder
ses distances de ne pas se rapprocher
alors que la danse c'est exactement
l'inverse de ça est-ce que ça a changé
vous diriez un rapport au corps bah oui
parce que de toute façon à l'école on a
donné des cours online et donc bon quand
tu as eu des stages je disais bon on va
on va parce que le cours que l'on
commence chez moi ma technique c'est de
s'embrasser de se toucher de se sentir
mais c'est essentiel de sentir l'autre
donc ça a changé quelquefois parce que
on a dit bon on va se coucher avec la
Lune vous avez les fesses pour moi dans
ma technique c'est la lune le soleil ici
est le pubis les étoiles donc le cosmos
était en nous avec les gestes barrières
donc on se dit bonjour hop avec la lune
bon ça mûri il y a des bons côtés des
mauvais côtés il faut voir toujours le
bon côté pendant que cette pandémie je
crois que ça a mûri ça fait réfléchir
les corps ça fait mûrir les corps et
donc en contact et après mais quand nous
avons repris la première c'était à
Madrid ça a été une explosion de joie de
danser et de prouver que le corps le
corps ne ment pas cette vérité cette
sensation de puissance réveille le monde
et donne à vivre ça fait combien
d'années que vous dansez jamais un
inconnu alors j'ai vraiment commencé
comme on dit professionnel
j'ai fait mes écoles à l'école Simon
Siel à Paris et donc à 19 20 ans que
j'ai commencé ça fait 60 ans
et pour vous avoir vu danser il y a deux
jours c'est incroyable l'énergie que
vous avez dites-nous comment on fait
pour avoir encore cette énergie là et
cette envie et dites-nous ce que vous
avez envie de dire vous encore en
dansant aujourd'hui
ben écoutez c'est le plaisir de danser
et quand on a du plaisir pour soi on
donne du plaisir à l'autre moi justement
c'est dense qui m'habitent vous savez à
Toubab Djala à l'école des sables je me
lève le matin je marche au bord de l'eau
je sens les oiseaux je sens la nature
j'ai tous cette nature qui se trouve en
moi et j'ai envie de l'exprimer et avec
Malou quand nous sommes rencontrés ben
ça a été nous avons nous sommes des mers
nous sommes des grands-mères nous aimons
la vie
tout cela nous avons voulu l'exprimer à
travers des gestes simples par exemple
quand elle est arrivée chez moi j'ai des
une arthrose terrible ça se voit pas
alors j'ai mis mes pieds dans l'eau et
elle a dit je vais faire comme toi et
justement cette sensation de de voilà
donc d'entraide d'amour de de sensations
extraordinaire c'est ce qui nous a
rapproché se rapprocher nous avons vécu
nous avons
vieilli ensemble mais ce que nous avons
envie de dire c'est d'être ensemble les
gestes de tous les jours voilà la
tendresse
que nous avons en ce moment avec qui
prépare vous savez cette tendresse et
justement ce calme ces douceurs de la
vie qui prépare après à cet explosion je
trouve ça extraordinaire qui est le
sacre juste après vous est effectivement
mal ouais quand on vous voit danser avec
cette cette femme qui a dansé donc pour
Pina Bao je pense à cette phrase phrase
qui revient à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure depuis nabot je suis bien connu
danser danser sinon nous sommes perdus
d'être venu ce matin sur notre plateau
donc vraiment je vous le dis si vous
êtes à Paris et que vous avez l'occasion
c'est jusqu'à vendredi je crois le Sacre
du printemps au Théâtre de la Ville
c'est absolument extraordinaire on vous
souhaite une très belle continuation et
donc un appel au
contributeur pour continuer sa vie
l'école des Slaves aux gens et à vivre
au Sénégal